For so long,
I had Larry in my ear or in my face telling
me what was real, what was not.
What was me, what was not.
I have no idea what's true.
Other than what I saw myself that I can
remember right now in this moment, sitting
here talking to you. I don't I mean, you
know, even part of that, how much it was of
that was real or true or was it, you know.
Can I ask you one question?
Yes.
Do you remember meeting Bernard Kerik?
When I was little? Yeah, because they knew my
family.Yeah.
Okay. So you remember meeting Bernard Kerik,
but is there any way that that could not be
true?
That's very unlikely. So.
But you see you.
Right. But you see where I am now?
Yeah.
What's real?
What's what's the truth? I don't know.